xavier moreau bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france tout d'abord pour
revenir sur cette rencontre entre olaf
scholz et joe biden hier à washington
qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir de la
posture des deux chefs d'état à l'issue
de cette rencontre
ont écouté rien rien de vraiment nouveau
évidemment berlin est l'interlocuteur
privilégié de washington en europe
puisque c'est là la grande puissance
économique
qui dé facto en fait dirigé l'union
européenne est en revanche du côté
allemand on sait très bien que
l'allemagne ne peut se passer du gaz
russe donc en fait chacun est resté sur
ses positions et tout le monde fait
semblant de croire qu'il ya un risque
d'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie et
que des mesures doivent être prises pour
menacer pour essayer de contraintes de
la russie à ne pas entreprendre cette
invasion virtuel donc rien de vraiment
nouveau sous le soleil et je dirais que
tout s'est déroulé un peu comme prévu
alors vous parlez des désaccords
notamment sur le gazoduc north stream 2
c'est quoi le problème de fond en fait
je voulais au même moment où schmoll se
rencontrent by denis à une réunion à
washington pour essayer de trouver des
alternatives qui n'existe pas au gaz
russe puisque il ya dix jours le chef du
gouvernement norvégien donc la norvège
et le deuxième fournisseur de gaz à
l'allemagne a déclaré qu'il ne pourrait
pas faire plus que ce qu'ils font
maintenant le ministre l'énergie qatar
il ya un peu moins d'une semaine a
déclaré la même chose que le qatar ne
pourrait pas remplacer le gaz russe qui
représente officiellement 40 % et à mon
avis même plus de 50% de la consommation
du gaz en europe et qui représente pour
l'allemagne spécifiquement 55% de sa
conso moy la consommation de gaz donc
toutes ces discussions autour des
sanctions qu'on pourrait mettre sur la
russie sont vaines dans la mesure où il
ya une réalité je dirais géologique et
énergétiques qui fait que l'allemagne ne
peut absolument pas se passer du gaz
russe ce qui n'empêche pas l'allemagne
d'envoyer des soldats en soutien aux
américains également
écouter oui alors la loi et des soldats
en lituanie les russes n'ont absolument
pas envie d'envahir la lituanie c'est un
espèce de no man's land économique est
désormais la population lituanienne
migrent vers la vers l'allemagne vers
vers les états unis pardon vert vers
l'angleterre pour travailler donc en
fait le les pays baltes ne sont pas un
objectif stratégique et encore moins
militaro stratégique pour la russie tous
à cesser de c'est de l'agitation dans le
même temps le président français lui
était à moscou des avancées souligné par
vladimir poutine également par emmanuel
macron est ce qu'il ya une divergence de
postures entre l'allemagne et la france
vis-à-vis des américains
non je ne pense pas que je crois que
là-dessus il ya une certaine convergence
et surtout l'idée qu' il faut il ne faut
pas laisser le dialogue direct désormais
qui a entre washington et moscou
chassez berlin et paris
d'aidés destinées de l'europe donc c'est
ce à quoi on assiste en fait c'est à
dire que evans et le maquereau est venu
pour essayer de comment dire de
contourner ce désormais ce lien direct
entre entre moscou et washington
en proposant une sortie de crise à
moscou on verra ce que ça donne mais ça
va plutôt dans la bonne direction même
si on peut être assez sceptique sur la
la réalité sur la volonté
in fine et des manèges macron d'avancé
sur l'application des accords de minsk
par l'ukraine
on peut parler donc selon vous du d'un
des buts des escalades finalement
aujourd'hui
il ya des signes assez positif par
exemple emmanuel macron n'est pas venu
les mains vides
rencontrer vladimir poutine puisqu'il
avait obtenu du président ukrainien
qu'il retire une loi qui devait être
prise en décembre dernier qui en fait
aurait rendu caduque l'application des
accords de minsk par le cren et ça a
d'ailleurs été répété lors de la
conférence de presse qu'ils aient en
commun c'est à dire que mails macron a
obtenu du présent et lenski qu'il retire
cette loi est ce que ça va aller plus
loin à mon avis ce qu'on aura c'est un
cessez le feu peut être un échange de
prisonniers
vraisemblablement pas d' amnistie
important ça fait partie des accords de
minsk mais je pense pas que emmanuel
macron obtiennent tienne cela et sans
doute pas du tout un accord d'autonomie
sur le sur le dôme basse puisque
d'ailleurs le ministre des affaires
étrangères ukrainien couler bas et le
secrétaire général du conseil de
sécurité ukrainiens monsieur danilov on
dit qu'il ne fallait pas appliquer cette
partie des accords de minsk donc à moins
que tout d'un coup emmanuel macron se
soit décidée après sept ans à faire
appliquer les accords de minsk par kiev
avec le soutien de l'allemagne je ne
pense pas qu'on ait tellement plus loin
que que ce que cela c'est-à-dire cessez
le feu et peut-être des échanges de
prisonniers en tout cas ce qui est ce
qui est intéressant c'est que vladimir
poutine écouter même macron sans doute
pour la raison que j'ai donné au début
de
demain remarques c'est à dire que et
même à croire obtenu le retrait d'une
loi qui aurait annulé defacto les
accords de minsk kiev qui de son côté a
relativisé le risque d'une invasion
russe il ya quelques jours concrètement
aux mises en garde aux avertissements de
washington comment est-ce que vous
décrypter cette cette prise de position
ukrainienne
d'après les chiffres officiels le cren a
perdu avec cette scic au drame de 2,2 de
l'invasion virtuelle de la russie 13 5
milliards de dollars de son économie
pourquoi bien parce que après avoir fait
peur à la population ukrainienne la
population coréenne s'est précipité pour
aller retirer son argent des banques la
l'économie s'est trouvée tout d'un coup
paralysé tous les expatriés qui
travaillent en ukraine et les compagnies
étrangères ont quitté l'ukraine donc ça
a été une véritable claque économique
pour une économie qui est déjà quasiment
à la limite de la banqueroute donc
c'était une véritable catastrophe et
alors que kiev avait initié ce mouvement
de panique finalement les déclarations
cette fois du président zelensky du
ministère de la défense ou ou des
différents ministères ukrainiens si
c'était demande aux occidentaux d'
arrêter de faire peur parce que ça va
entraîner une catastrophe économique qui
a déjà commencé donc la réalité est là
c'est à dire qu'on a voulu jouer à faire
peur aux ukrainiens à faire peur on va
dire aux pays occidentaux de faire les
faire craindre une invasion de la russie
qui ne dont il n'a jamais été question
et maintenant on en est
à faire machine arrière pour essayer
d'empêcher l'effondrement complet de
l'économie ukrainienne voilà tout
simplement la raison en tout cas un
marathon diplomatique qui va continuer
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui à kiev
ensuite il doit rencontrer à nouveau
vladimir poutine olaf scholz également à
kiev qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre après
ce marathon diplomatique comme je le
disais dans les prochains jours
écoutez ce que l'on peut attendre c'est
qu'en fait il ne va rien se passer dans
le camp de base d'ici la fin février
de toute manière le climat ne permet
aucune manoeuvre militaire de la part de
kiev cessé de l'an ce moment c'est le
dégel il fait extrêmement chaud pour un
bon univers donc il ne se passera rien
militairement et comme je voulais dit ce
qu'on peut espérer c'est un cessez le
feu bon peut-être un échange de
prisonniers j'y crois pas trop mais on
pourrait avoir peut-être une amnistie un
début d amnistie et de toute manière je
ne crois toujours pas qu'il y aura un
accord sur un statut d'autonomie du
donbass qui pourtant fait partie des
accords de munich mais kiev n'est pas
prêt n'est pas prêt à l'appliquer donc
voilà je il faut être on peut être
optimiste mais modérément merci beaucoup
xavier moreau pour votre éclairage ce
matin je le rappelle vous êtes directeur
de strates paul